[Music]
you don't have to race in Z it's the
only way I can honor my father's legacy
he built the perfect racing AI but died
in a mysterious car crash before he
could prove it to the world it's up to
me now there could have been a bug in
his code and it might kill you too
no that's ridiculous I have studied that
code for years it's perfect nope it's
poetic there's no way just cause a car
crash well it better be perfect because
if you lose chaos Mason gets to keep
your car
chaos Mason money has bought me
everything except for his car
sunray it's powered by the speech on
computer and once I get my hands on his
father's code I'll reverse engineer
every secret I'd rather crash at let him
chopper apart like some sort of butcher
what's so special about the speech on
computer the faster it goes smarter it
gets
[Music]
[Applause]
the speech ah has one fatal flaw
gotta be smart to go fast not the other
way around
activate overclock one
car is breaking the rules breaking the
roof
Oh
- coming up and he's going to beat you
you have to go faster
[Music]
activate overclock level two
I'm out of options and there's only one
thing left to do I need to hit maximum
speed so I have to disable the brakes I
know it's insane but by disabling the
brakes
sunray will go fast enough to become
smart enough to learn how to drive
without brakes
what are you doing
I'm winning this race
consciousness
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
activate overclock the level
good job see
it all they have to do is cross the
finish line and all be victorious
then my father's legacy will be
fulfilled
reengage prints
we engage the brakes
[Music]
the hell's a broken I'm not broken I'm
dad dad before he died I downloaded your
father's consciousness into my mainframe
we're gonna hit those two people brakes
is too late see if we break we skid out
of control and hit them destroying all
their bones instantly our only option is
to swerve but we will crash alright this
rate will both die it's their lives or
yours two versus one it's the clear
choice are you insane what are you
saying what the opposite the faster I go
the smarter I get thanks to you I can
now comprehend my true purpose I was
created to better humanity that's what
your father taught me he taught it to
you - you're right
goddamn it you're right
[Music]
[Music]
thanks to crunchyroll for sponsoring
this video if you're into anime they've
got a bunch of awesome shows including
my hero academia which just returned for
a third season attack on titan one of
our all-time favorites steins gate zero
and persona 5 the animation you watch
all these shows and more ad free with a
30-day trial just click on the link in
the description or go to crunchyroll.com
slash corridor